sponsored by step finance your go to
d5 portfolio manager once bitmex the
og crypto derivatives platform and
the best place to buy your bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh
plan show so this podcast is sponsored by
the og crypto derivatives exchange bitmex so
bitmex has actually just launched a brand new
spot exchange so now you can easily buy and
sell many different cryptocurrencies including
bitcoin on their exchange so if you do want to use
their exchange i'm going to leave the information
for you a link to them in the description so
definitely pick bitmex as your number one exchange
also on this podcast we talk about all the things
that you're sort of not allowed to speak about
including authoritarianism censorship
freedom bitcoin and all these things
and so a massive thank you to bit max because
without them we wouldn't be able to bring you
such important conversations now before i kick
the show off please don't forget to hit the
like button and hit subscribe so you never miss a
video and also so that you can support these very
important conversations that we're having joining
me today is heidi the host of the super popular
youtube show crypto tips heidi is an early bitcoin
adopter and also she's been through two bear
markets and three bull markets let's kick this off
hey leia it's great to be here thank you so much
for having me let's talk about it yeah i'm really
excited there's so many interesting things going
on um i think your story is really unique but
before we get into all of that i do want to learn
a little bit more um about you because this is the
first time we're meeting um you call yourself an
early adopter tell me what that means how did you
first hear about bitcoin um yeah so i first was
introduced to bitcoin in about 2014 late 2014 from
the person who is now my husband uh he actually
was trying to yeah inform me about it and
through that just learning more and more about
how a currency could exist outside of the control
of the government how it can be valid and not
scammed and and duplicated and and all that so
uh it was a long journey of education for me
because i'm coming from not a tech background
not an uh financial uh background either
or computer science so it was all really new for
me so i mean if you you want to talk about an
early adopter mindset what that means basically
i think anyone now can also be an early adopter
i mean there's still plenty of people around that
are denying bitcoin that our thing is still it's
just a fad or for whatever reason i think
if you're like surrounded by people who are
putting it down and yet you can still see
the potential in something despite having
this kind of uh confirmation bias surrounding you
uh that's kind of like an early adopter mindset
you can have in a lot of different things but
including crypto too but you said that the way
your now husband basically put this forward to
you was this money which is you know outside of
government control so that's quite a libertarian
and political mindset so for you was it
you know the games was it the tech
or was it the political philosophy
um i mean obviously the gains is what draws a
lot of people in but for me um also having this
like kind of a nomadic lifestyle thinking of
a currency that you can hold and transact in
across borders without permission without having
to deal with banks in different countries is very
attractive as well yeah definitely the type of
people who are interested in bitcoin has evolved
from the cypherpunks to the anarchists to the
liberal uh the the uh other people who are you
know anti-government or whatever now it's just
people who are trying to hedge against inflation
and so the narrative is constantly changing for
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies but uh yeah so yeah
before before we get into the whole
anti-government thing because for those
that don't know you run out to a u.s citizenship
which is mind-blowing to me and i can't wait to
ask you about that um so stick around because
we're gonna get into that um but i wanna just
get your take on the markets um because you know
you have been through several different cycles now
um and a lot of people say that this current cycle
is different to all the other cycles we've seen
because of all the institutional money that's now
involved um so what's your take on where we're at
yeah i definitely agree with i know willy woo
was putting that out too how over time the uh
the dramatic volatility of bitcoin is going to
be diminished and it makes sense because as the
market cap is growing it takes more heavier
waves to to rock the boat that is bitcoin so
also furthermore like okay 2000 again let's go
through like the different bull runs 2012 and 2013
2014 that was uh again very small market cap very
little amount of money was needed to to make that
price go up and same uh reverse 2017 was when
mainstream media was like pumping it out to people
and they were taking their investment advice
from you know msnbc and fox news and and and
things like this and they weren't really
understanding why it was created and the
importance of it it was just like the beginning of
kind of meme coins for cryptocurrencies so again
it was really shallow understanding of crypto
and that shallow understanding was represented in
how how crazy the fomo was in 2017 2018 and
the reverse when it started backpedaling when
those uh irrational investors were no longer there
to support that type of buying pressure um so uh
and now yeah what i said before it's like we have
countries having bitcoin as legal tender we have
publicly traded companies that have bitcoin on
their books and they're doing so because they
trust bitcoin in a certain on a certain level
much more than they would with their fiat or
any other options they would have for investing
so it's a a much more deeper understanding and
a trust and less speculation i think um that
we're seeing now so i i agree with willy woo
that it's gonna be less dramatic of a of a
blow off top you know everyone was saying
oh 2021 was that a blow off top i don't think
so um does that mean that this bear market is
going to be as long and drawn out or as dramatic
as we've seen in the past as well who knows um
it's everyone wants to know everyone wants
to know what the crystal ball is going to say
for what the market is doing but what i
am constantly leaning on is the long-term
uh you know prospects of bitcoin and what it
actually the utility that is bringing to everyone
you don't have to be an accredited investor to
buy bitcoin you don't have to be an institutional
investor or you know you don't need any
credentials so uh it's a pretty cool thing to see
grow and yeah uh the profits are still there for
sure but maybe not as dramatic as before but let's
so let's talk more about the utility because you
said that you're 100 certain of bitcoin success
which is so funny because like to me that's
that's obvious but there's a lot of people who are
heavily involved in in this industry heavily
involved in crypto who just think you know it's
all tech um it's done it's finished um so how
can you be 100 certain of bitcoin's success
um it is the most okay so there's been attempts
at cryptocurrency since like the 1970s with the
cyberpunk movement and they've been failing
over and over and over again and satoshi was
the first one to find the solution that didn't
revolve centralized control over the network
and that's what has has you know bred
this whole crypto space as we know it
um so bitcoin's been tested since 2009. um and
others cryptocurrencies obviously it's been an
open source community and you can learn from the
mistakes and you can make different trade-offs
but to say that even proof of stake is tested and
guaranteed is false in my opinion that's arguably
not true um we haven't seen the proof of stake be
tested like bitcoin has and there's many reasons
for that just the way that the consensus mechanism
is different um bitcoin if you hold a bunch of
bitcoin that doesn't that doesn't directly
give you a right to change how the network
functions proof of stake does so that is very that
is a very different concept and something that
people should be paying attention to but yeah
so people who say like bitcoin is is old tech
and they're gonna come out with like this brand
new solution like they have a brand new consensus
mechanism they did something totally new it's so
good for marketing and for getting people excited
but when i hear that i hear it's brand new it's
untested it's so like we saw what happened with
with ust and with anchor protocol um we're seeing
what what's happening with solana that was like
the new ethereum killer in 2021 that blockchain's
been down like 20 something times in the past year
so uh yeah it's it's a lot of i think eager people
uh coming to the space but yeah i i feel like i'm
not i don't consider myself a bitcoin maximalist
that's about ascii i'm happy to see a different
crypt i've invested in other cryptocurrencies
certainly but as time moves on i think more people
fall like realize the solidity that bitcoin has
and they lean back on that and then you know they
they still uh well i can't speak for everyone but
for me personally um just kind of sprinkle around
a different cryptos and see what happens but
what is but what does bitcoin's success mean like
in what capacity do you would you
say okay that's been successful
the ability to transact freely in a peer-to-peer
fashion without censorship uh the incentive model
for the bitcoin network is in my opinion so solid
um the threat of overrunning the network from any
government from any one entity is is out of
the reach unless you know you're going to
print your fiat currency into oblivion just
to take over the bitcoin network is kind of
ridiculous um so yeah in my opinion what it was
put out for was for peer-to-peer transactions
and censorship resistance and it has done that
since day one so um for me that's successful
so it's speaking of governments and everything you
you said that you think that hang on i actually i
actually have the quote here you said within a
couple of years i predict that bitcoin mining
will be completely banned in every single
state in the us the writing is on the wall
um that was pr you came down pretty harsh on
that um why do you think that the us is gonna
totally um you know ban bitcoin mining um yeah
i think that this is definitely a representation
of my mindset towards the us generally that's
why i made a decision to pronounce as i did
but it's something like what we were seeing
with new york right they kind of teased
it that they were gonna ban bitcoin oh and
then they didn't and then uh some of the the
lawmakers there were flipped and so now they're
deciding to actually pass the bill on to uh the
the governor to sign it into law or to veto it
but so it's i don't know it the the us is such
a powerhouse that it is and bitcoin equally
such a powerhouse and how disruptive it is
i am very skeptical that the us would be copacetic
with bitcoin um and yeah with bitcoin mining i
mean of course you can mine bitcoin off the grid
you can uh do it anonymously but to for it to be
i don't know it could easily go the way of china
um and and i i'm just very i'm very skeptical
and i yeah probably just super pessimistic about
any kind of innovation coming from the us at this
point yeah so let's talk about that you run out
your u.s citizenship which is so wild because i'm
moving to the u.s i'm not becoming a
citizen um but i'm just moving there
so i can stay there longer than three months
um why did you renounce your u.s citizenship
yeah well we're all making different decisions
based on where our lives are taking us and for
different reasons but um ever since i left the us
the first time i left the country i found myself
wanting to live outside i don't know i felt for
example the first place i went was portugal and
that's where i live now for most of the time for
six months out of the year and i felt more at
home in that country than i did in the home that
i grew up in and spent 25 years of my life so that
was the first kind of fraction for me it was like
okay if i'm not going to live there why would i
still be what what benefit is it for me to
have ties to a country that is uh pretty uh
annoying to have to deal with uh for paperwork
if you want to bank outside the us if you want to
sometimes if you want to invest in different funds
outside the us you're on you aren't allowed to
um with fbar and facta and all these things it's
like it's pretty annoying and especially when you
already know that you're not interested in living
there it's really pointless not to mention the
fact that you can obtain second citizenship second
passports that allow you to travel to just as
many if not more countries that the us does so i
first obtained a second citizenship in preparation
for that change and then yeah i i haven't
regretted it since i renounced in 2019 and uh
looking at how the us is going now i i mean i
should obviously mention there's living outside
the us and there's also cryptocurrencies that
was like the number one and number two reason i
could see again with regulations how they were
bottle-ducked and just like suffocating the us
citizens and their ability to freely access
cryptocurrencies um so yeah there's i mean there's
finance.us versus binance.com there's some even
decentralized exchanges where if you're identified
as u.s citizen you can't use it if you wanted to
invest in an ico or a new project and you were a
us citizen you couldn't invest in it so for me it
was uh that's like the main reason i'm so excited
it's just for the crypto reasons but
yeah there's there's definitely a few
was it difficult because i heard that in order
to renounce you have to like pay like crazy exit
taxes and stuff like that you don't have to get
into too much detail obviously yeah no there's
definitely uh depending on your net worth at the
time of announcement you might have to pay an exit
tax which is basically a percentage on everything
that you own in addition to that you are called a
covered expatriate and that means that if you were
ever to like send money to family or to someone
in the u.s that would be taxed or if your net
worth was under a certain threshold you just pay
a regular you pay your last tax as you normally
would on your income but there's no additional tax
on your total net worth you do have to account for
your total net worth so they can determine if you
are a covered or uncovered expatriate but that was
pretty straightforward for me i didn't fall under
that threshold so i didn't have to pay an exit
tax um thankfully the crypto was in a fair market
when i renounced um also i renounced in the
bahamas which was very easy and fast process
i i'm not sure what it is like now to renounce
with all of the global lockdowns and the different
i think i've heard from a few people that a few of
the different us embassies won't let you renounce
unless you are a resident of that country um
so like for example i wasn't a resident of the
bahamas but i just went there and i renounced um
and you do have to pay a renouncement fee which
i think it used to be like seven hundred dollars
and then about five years ago they bumped it up to
2300 or something like that um you can
pay cash or credit but good to know
um that really blows my mind as well because like
i think um you know even though i'm moving to the
states i still have an emotion i still have an
emotional connection to the uk where i'm from
um and so i don't know i mean obviously it's
different like it's so different you know you
can be a resident of another country and you
still have to pay u.s taxes being british you
don't write like that it's so easy you can go
anywhere and you know you're not followed or or
anything like that and for your money but did you
not feel some kind of like emotional or like do
you have any like identity crisis because like
that's overbought you know you lived there for
years like was there no emotional difficulty in
doing that i mean i really i don't want to speak
badly about where i come from and and the town
that i lived in but it was a very small town
very small town mindset um a lot of people worked
very hard for very little money they're just
scraping by they're like living for the weekend
they're getting drunk at the at the bar every
weekend like it wasn't a very inspiring place
to be so when i did step out of that and start
traveling i you know met so many other people that
were inspiring and healthy and you know just like
encouraging so for me i felt i feel more of a tie
to other places than my hometown of course i love
my family who is still there i see them frequently
as a renowned citizen you can still go back to the
us you just have to apply for a visa just like
everyone else is not a us citizen basically
um but yeah so i didn't it wasn't as much of an
emotional thing for me uh which i don't know maybe
i have something missing that didn't affect me
that much but i also had a very supportive family
that didn't try to guilt me about anything
like they were very encouraging like listen
i understand you got to do what you got
to do we love you and this is your life
and it's amazing so yeah i've had a lot of
encouragement so that probably helped as well
that's amazing is your husband from the same
place or did you meet him like on your journey
no he's from california too he renounced about
six months or yeah six to eight months after me so
yeah that's crazy no i think that's so fascinating
um the the contrast and like the difference um
is crazy but i i do understand it i just i don't
know emotionally i feel like you do end up sort of
i don't know identifying with where you're from
so you have citizenship where now then portugal
in saint kitts and nevis it's a caribbean ah
nice okay that's amazing um so in times of
adoption and you know your issue with the us
you said that you think that it's going to
come from a federal level not at a state level
um sorry so to what yeah can you hear me okay
yeah is it delayed no no no you're good yeah
okay so you said that it's gonna come from a
federal level instead of a state level um so what
are the issues that you're seeing on a federal
level um in terms of crypto obviously but i guess
i'm also on a broader from kind of like a broader
uh perspective it might be interesting to hear
well we're like what we're seeing for example
with grayscale in the sec or what we're seeing
with um the bank in wyoming the name is escaping
me right now uh from caitlyn long her bank in
wyoming and they're suing the federal reserve
um there's always going to be that glass ceiling
from the federal reserve from the federal level
because that's where the money is that's what
they're protecting is their global reserve
currency in the us dollar um as much as like
the the states want to do what they want to do
like we're seeing with caitlyn long and like they
were working great with the kansas city federal
reserve and then at a certain point the big fed
stepped in and suddenly it's been 19 months when
normally it takes five to seven days for them
to make a decision so um yeah i think it is
it's like you know the american dream
or whatever the american way to have
state level governments but at a certain point
it's like you have a big brother that is like
the biggest brother of the world that's gonna
make sure it's gonna look out for itself and
it's gonna make whatever narrative they can about
crypto to protect their special interests so yeah
unless you secede from the us or something
i'm very skeptical that you can have a state
uh be fully as crypto free or whatever as they'd
like to be because you're you're always gonna
have to pay federal taxes um and federal laws
exist so yeah that's what i was meaning by that
do you think that um america's always had this
big brother um or or do you think at one point
the american dream was still was a reality and
it's kind of shifted yeah i think it's i think the
american dream was reality until like the 70s when
you could have a thriving household on one income
now if you know two people working two jobs
kids are indica i mean we can go and tell how
it's dilapidated but um yeah i don't think it's
always been that way but uh i think that the way
technology has has shifted and certain things have
happened around the world and the way that they've
kind of taken advantage of those situations to
advance their power grabs uh yeah i think it's
it's become especially apparent especially if
you travel if you travel to different countries
you can see how uh things are different i know
like the uk in london there's cctv like every
inch of the whole country if you go to like the
train stations it's like you look like a bunch of
yeah cameras pointing at you so um yeah i'm
probably getting off topic there but no it's been
a big brother thing but yeah do you think
that um so obviously you're moving you're
not your u.s citizenship so do you think that
the not all countries are going to be hostile
towards crypto but not just crypto just
general like this authoritarian kind of um
this increase in like censorship
authoritarianism that we're seeing globally
um do you think that this is going to be us
only or are we going to see this everywhere
i think okay so i remember i did a video on this
in like 2017 about crypto called like the global
flipping talking about how some countries who have
had it good have had some kind of authority over
how the economies are are running around the world
and global trade have had it so good for so long
that yeah they're the ones going to be disrupted
and then there's other countries that are just
waiting for the opportunity some kind of a step
up whatever shortcut they can to get that that leg
ahead and el salvador uh we're seeing it in africa
as well um and so and with covid or i'm sorry i
shouldn't say that but with the global lockdowns
that were happening no red flags for the algorithm
with the global lockdowns that were happening
there was the countries that were not so strict
with their regulations in that regard and people
were flooding there because like mexico for
example um and there were countries like just
with the you know the required health the juice
like some countries that re refused to make
mandates and some that did um so and they've
benefited from that so i think that there's always
if if a country or government is hungry enough or
willing to go against the grain to a certain point
they will benefit and i think i think what we're
gonna see with el salvador it's gonna be crazy
since even last year they adopted bitcoin and
their gdp grew by 10 for the first time and not
only just because they had bitcoin on their books
and it was like a bull run but also because
tourism is coming in people want to go where
people can use their bitcoin and know that it's
friendly and have that experience and actually
integrate it into their life um i know in in nevis
uh one of the countries at saint kitts and nevis
uh they have like it's everywhere bitcoin cash
is everywhere um my lawyer who helped me get my
citizenship there she said she basically pays
for rent because her grocery is everything in
crypto so yeah it's uh it's gonna be i think
a slow transition uh to see what when these
countries really start popping up but absolutely
it's i don't think it's gonna be a global thing
there's of course there's a world economic
forum there's all these like kind of global
uh powers that are going to try to keep everyone
in line but whether it's actually enforced locally
in that country i think is has a lot of wiggle
room so do you genuinely think there's going to
be this global flipping essentially whereby the
whereby america may not be you know the big bad
america anymore and there could be other countries
which really bring themselves onto the the
financial map they just basically get a c at the
table i hope so yeah absolutely imagine an economy
built on something like bitcoin where it's a
known cap supply inflation isn't a threat you
know exactly how much is going to exist when
and for whatever reason um and compared to
you know oh we gotta print this much money because
whatever decision we're gonna spend it here
you have no say in that whatsoever but you're
the victim of it through that hidden tax that
is inflation so uh yeah i hope that they get
shaken up i think they've been on they've been
top dog for too long they've taken it for granted
and it's at the expense of the citizens so yeah
but it's interesting because this would
you know you mentioned the word economic
forum and like there's this whole narrative um
being pushed that bitcoin is you know either
um bad for the environment um it's uh supported
by lunatics right-wing alt-right kind of
illiterate lunatics create every everything
i think even like i'm seeing things like um
people that go to the gym tend to be more
right-wing there's like this this huge weird push
um that i'm seeing going on so why why do you
think that's happening um and where do you
think it's coming from oh because they're scared
that's why they you know the narrative was always
oh bitcoin is for criminals even though
technically most people don't know how
to do bitcoin in a really and really private
manner so it's like pseudo-anonymous basically so
a lot of criminals don't use bitcoin because it's
like very easily traced um but and now actually
the u.s treasury came out with a report i'm not
sure exactly how long ago it's like it was within
the year saying that the uh amount of transactions
happening for illicit activity on with bitcoin
is like a drop in the bucket like completely
minuscule compared to other traditional financial
uh tools like cash or whatever banking you name
it but so um the narrative is always changing and
it's always because it's a threat and um the thing
with the with the energy consumption of bitcoin
that is laughable um if you do any research
whatsoever you'll learn that like 60 of bitcoin
mining is done with renewable energy and not to
mention the fact that um there this push for like
okay so it's really interesting what's happening
with ethereum and their move from proof of work
to proof of stake it's really weird timing
because it's like falling in line with this
esg narrative that they're pushing so much
when in reality ethereum was planning this
since the day it was launched in 2015 it was
planning to be proof of stake and now it's like
it's like all of a sudden politically correct
as well um but again this uh a lot of people
think like oh well what if bitcoin goes to proof
of stake some people who are saying that i mean
anyone who who has really done their research
on bitcoin knows that's never gonna happen
uh for many different reasons but even that
concept of using that narrative oh it's it's
more energy efficient but again going back to what
i said about proof-of-stake how it's different
from proof-of-work is that suddenly these whales
can change the network how it functions can come
together and change just because they're holding a
lot of bitcoin um so i think it's really important
to have that separation of running the network
and interacting with it and the coins involved so
um yeah they're they're just gonna find something
to try to to try to scare either that or or
they're trying to push down the price so then
they can buy more before it pumps again i don't
know uh yeah but it's definitely coming from fear
but having by the way can you hear me okay because
i'm seeing comments that my mic is isn't working
very well so can you hear me clearly yeah you can
hear me clearly okay so guys let me know in the
comments if you can hear me i don't know what's
wrong um so with all with all these like bizarre
narratives that are coming out um apparently my
mic is better now that's great thanks guys um so
with all these bizarre narratives that's coming
out um it's so interesting because having these
conversations people often call you a conspiracy
theorist and they think you're crazy um and all
this stuff and um i mentioned this actually on
a few episodes that a few episodes ago that i
did and um i was talking to somebody at a party
and i said something like you know the president
joe biden he can't even string a full sentence
together and somebody screamed to me was like
you're a conspiracy theorist and i'm like
bro like just watch a video um so how do you
how do you like navigate these ideas and this
world and you're trying to wake people up without
being called a conspiracy theorist and how do you
get people to take what you're saying seriously
yeah it's definitely a balance between you know
not wasting your time and not like throwing your
pearls to the swine you know what i mean like i i
it's not i i haven't made it my mission to like
convince everyone to think what i think but uh
there are some red flags that i feel the need to
like just shut it out and then if someone you know
once wants to understand it or look more into it
that's great um but yeah conspiracy theorists are
critical thinker i don't know i feel like those
are kind of synonymous these days uh but you got
to go back to also that early adopter mindset
like uh you know there's a lot of people who
can see what was happening with bitcoin and the
importance of it i mean also talk about like okay
talk about foresight and the cypherpunk movement
in 1993 eric hughes wrote the cypherpunk manifesto
if you haven't read it i highly recommend
it these guys understood the importance of
encryption and protecting people's privacy rights
online through communications that was in 1993
that was like way before the internet took off
and that's the kind of foresight they had um and
they volunteered their time they weren't paid for
this in any any way and that movement eventually
culminated into the creation of cryptocurrencies
as well so you have to you know not count anything
out take it all with a grain of salt but also
be aware and see what is happening and also
be a little skeptical over why certain
things are going down the way that they are
um i mean you don't have to go completely crazy
and like neurotic and like hide in a bunker in
your house or whatever but like you can definitely
also benefit from trying to understand what's
happening and be strategic and flexible in your
life to to you know not get taken out or you know
maybe possibly even benefit at the very least not
get taken out you know yeah and this this whole
conversation sort of goes further than i know
everything is about money but it goes further than
that because i know a lot of americans are having
issues with um like the the farmland now which is
totally being bought up by um bill gates um i
saw that um i think a chicken farm or something
was totally burnt down the other day um and that
was like owned by a family or something and that
had that had been around for like decades and has
always been fine um so like food is is a really
big topic i wondered if you had any thoughts
on farming and food or anything like that i
it's a skill that i feel like i should learn
like everyone should learn just in case something
happens also just like you know understanding
where your food is coming from i'm really
health conscious and you know try to eat
as organic as possible whenever i can
um but yeah obviously food is whatever you're
talking about if something has intrinsic value it
goes down to food it boils down to that um that's
where you like you know sustenance so yeah uh this
whole concept i know i don't know how familiar
are with like the world economic forum and their
ideas of like you know we're gonna
eat bugs and like just completely
chemically created meat or something i don't
know the more that they push that thing the more
you want to go the other way um and there's
so many hypocrisies in the members of that
forum and and they're versus what they're putting
out for example bill gates he flies his private
jet all over the place like and he's preaching
about saving the environment and things so yeah uh
i i'm very skeptical that they're actually looking
out for our own self-interest and not just trying
to push whatever they can for their own reasons so
i won't be eating any bugs unless it's by accident
how do you um how do you find yourself like
so sure of these things um because again it
always comes back to that conspiracy theorist
thing um like i'm aware of what's going on with
um the world economic forum um i know the whole
bug narrative um but whenever i speak to people
who aren't in my bubble um or my echo chamber
um they always think it's so crazy like i had
a family member around for um dinner last night
and um i was talking about bill gates and i was
sort of saying you know um well if he really
cared about the environment he wouldn't have
his short position on tesla did you see the text
that he sent elon musk and i'm getting like really
and my family and my family members just like
what no bill gates like totally cares about
the environment and you know he's doing i don't
understand like why some people don't see it so
clearly i think it's a lack of uh investigating on
their part i think a lot of people outsource their
their critical thinking to other people or they
just don't want to believe that there's such a
prevalent boogeyman right in front of them that's
actually really controlling everything about
their life the past two years should have been a
shining example of that um there's i mean i don't
want to get into that whole concept conversation
of what happened the past two years because that
can be very touchy but i think it's a perfect
example of how extreme things can get um and
yeah uh whenever i think of like people like
you're saying they don't believe you or whatever
i my unfortunate like you know my skepticism is
like well just wait and see like it's okay like
i don't have to be right you don't have
to be right we'll just wait and see
and i'm in the meantime i'm going to be
as strategic strategic as i can with my
life decisions where i invest my money where i
live where i travel to my health decisions um
and you can follow their narrative and see how
it goes for you but for me personally it's like
i find much more comfort in my own
knowledge and my own independent research
than whatever's is being spoon-fed to me you
know from whatever source it's like facebook or
social media or whatever they tend to be very
emotional about arguments and actually if you
most people if you find that they they're like
okay uh i like bill gates if you ask like okay
well what do you what does he do specifically that
you like they don't know they can't say anything
they just know that they heard somewhere sometime
he's a good guy or something or whatever so and
take that concept to like all these other things
that people should be questioning but they don't
it's very surface level belief that they have and
if you just ask a simple question why what do you
think about what this happened and they don't know
or it's just yeah and maybe that question that
you asked is good enough to send them on their way
down that rabbit hole to do their own research and
you've done a good job so where so where
do you think this whole thing is going um
because i know you've spoken a bit about cbdc's
i try and talk about cbdc's as much as possible
um you know by 2030 you'll have nothing and you'll
be happy bugs and all that great stuff where
it's so freaky it's literally like
a james bond movie it's like a
if it's where clash rob is a real james bond
villain but um where is this all going um yeah
cbdc's are such a scary thing for me to
think about how easy it will be for them to
to force that on people um but actually toby had
a really good point um we were talking about this
the other day my husband toby he was saying that
uh they're trying it could be that like all these
regulations that are being put on crypto through
they they use excuses like what happened with luna
and oh my gosh stable coins need to be regulated
they need to be identified you need a kyc if you
want to do a stable coin because it's in your
best interest and so they're trying to kind of
regulate crypto in such a way that it it's
going to be kind of synonymous with how a
cbdc is going to be functioning so they're kind of
like getting you used to uh interacting it because
if it wasn't regulated and it was totally
free you could only you know you could do a
open a crypto account with just a web with just an
email and password like you used to be able to do
um and now they try to bring in a central bank
stable coin that has all these different hiccups
and control and lack of privacy and it's not a
public blockchain and you can't see where your
transaction is going to but they can um it
would be such a stark difference that people
with any ounce of a brain would choose the other
option rather than a cbdc and you know the free
market would kind of win out in that way but
yeah i in the long term it's going to be probably
surface level if you have to interact with a cbdc
you do so at a minimum or you're completely off
the grid and you're all in the seedy underbelly
of decentralized privacy coins and cryptocurrency
um it sounds so orwellian when i'm describing
this whenever i think about it i had someone
we do an ama and i had someone ask me 15 years
from now let's say you're still living in the u.s
and let's say they've banned bitcoin and you've
never sold bitcoin and you're ready to retire
uh what do you do with crypto and i was like you
go to a different country that's adopted bitcoin
and he lives happily ever after there like at what
point like that's at what point is it worth it to
live in a country and contribute to that country
with your paying taxes um that you you have this
like moment where like uh nomad capitalist always
says go be your treated best i think that's
a great saying to have and live by um but yeah i
mean i understand there's people who are patriotic
i understand there's people who have family and
ties and for whatever reason they can't leave
but when push comes comes to shove at certain
point you have your limits and i wasn't willing
to wait to see how bad it gets before i left
uh that might be but it you know i had other
places to go that i'd rather go anyway so it
worked out but yeah not to get to doomsday on
here but i think there's definitely going to
be two worlds of cryptocurrency and the people
who know about bitcoin now are great they're
they're they have such such a a heads up and
step in the right direction of understanding how
to interact with crypto freely how to have your
own wallet how to use a decentralized exchange
um and just really simple things like that
because now you know we have paypal coming into
crypto we have uh so many wallet providers that
uh for d5 i've done i've been trying to find
research of like wallets outside of metamask
that you can use and so many of these these
wallets advertised they market themselves as being
user-friendly oh if you forget you don't have to
worry about your seed phrase if you forget your
password we can get it back because they're the
ones holding the seed like you don't have real
ownership but they don't say that and so people
who are coming in like that's been my mantra and
basically how i have this channel is like just to
remind people like no this is how you should do it
i know how convenient that is but i believe
in your ability to learn this i believe in
your ability to to do this the right way so
it's important and you said go where you're
treated best so you're in portugal so i'm really
interested to know what life is like in portugal
do you have like other like-minded people is
there a big crypto community and then i also
saw that there was going to be some regulation
or something on taxes but that didn't pass
yeah so i we moved to portugal in 2015. that
was before they made any announcement being
crypto friendly or no taxes on crypto we moved
to portugal because the low cost of living the
high quality of life surfing the food the people
oh my gosh the people at the locals are amazing
so i love portugal it feels like home for many
different reasons um and then in was it 2017
or 2018 they said they weren't going to tax crypto
and and it's been that way for several years until
this year i think they had the left side more in
their governments and so they're pushing for taxes
and i think there was some misinformation
on what happened it was about a month ago
uh i guess okay because i have a lawyer
in portugal and so she's into crypto and
she's like it's in her best interest to know
exactly what's happening here so she told me how
um there was this meeting that they were
going through this agenda to discuss with
the finance minister and at the end of the
meeting it was an unofficial question this
guy just off-handedly say hey are we going to tax
crypto and he said the finance minister said uh
listen there's been a a study that was requested
last year it hasn't been completed yet let alone
we haven't analyzed it yet um if and when you know
that happens we will analyze and make a decision
he refused to give any timeline of when it was
going to happen and then shortly after that i
think the left side was was putting up to vote to
approve some taxes for crypto and it was denied
so i don't think it's going to last forever
being tax free and crypt uh for uh portugal
but uh i mean enjoy it while you can if you are
here but speaking of the people who are coming
into portugal specifically for crypto yeah there's
been a lot of in uh all over the place actually
lisbon um there's these cafes and workspaces where
it's all crypto um there's no crypto exchange
oh it's frozen i don't know if that's just guys
can you let me know if it's me or if it's heidi
that's frozen oh can you hear me heidi uh
yeah can you hear me now yeah i don't know
if you if it was you or me that phrase but
i can hear you now it might have been mine
i think it was my wife that's good so far i'm
surprised i'm surprised my mic has been so
terrible honestly that's what i'm surprised about
i thought it was okay um but go on sorry you you
were saying like you don't think it's gonna
last but right now um it's good for people to
to come yeah i mean yeah i i think that you should
have an understanding that if you're coming here
specifically just because it's crypto free there's
there's this whole concept of like okay it's
crypto friendly it can either mean that there's
zero regulations but those regulations could come
in the future which is what portugal is right now
or there's really clear regulations you know what
you're going to be paying and it's solidified
in law and it's also a pretty small tax that's
like the best uh you know uh crypto friendly
friendliness so portugal it's not regulated so
it could go either way so if you're if you're
trying to you know base your life based on
uh where you're going to be paying your taxes for
crypto um it might be short lived in portugal but
there's lots of other reasons to move to
portugal too it's an awesome country but
not trying to shill portugal too hard i can't help
it no it's cool i i see portugal in my future at
some point i see at some point in my life if you
do you got to let me know we gotta i'll show you
around i will do no 100 i will um but where so
if portugal has these taxes potentially coming
um where are you bullish on long term um how
successful do you think el salvador is going to be
um i know they have their um no income tax no
capital gains tax on bitcoin and all this stuff so
um yeah what are your thoughts on that yeah
um i'd be here to see how their volcano mining
turns out as well i know they put that project
on hold because it didn't quite time out with
a bull market which we review is kind of weird
like you should just maybe you know push that
either way i think it's a good thing to do but
um yeah i'm i'm pretty i mean talk about crypto
being an experiment that's an experiment as well
yeah they've already benefited from it um i think
there's they're gonna be obviously feeling what it
is to have such a volatile uh asset as their legal
tender but i think generally over time just like
with any kind of investment in bitcoin generally
over time we're gonna do really well um so i'm
interested to see how they continue to build out
their infrastructure and how that's surrounded
by crypto and also how the locals feel about it
um usually when a country is trying to you
know create more wealth or stimulate some
kind of tourism unfortunately it's at the expense
of the locals like these new you know crypto rich
people come in and the the prices of property are
skyrocketing all of a sudden the locals can't even
afford to be there anymore so hopefully there's
some kind of regulation to protect them as well
or to benefit them specifically so uh that's what
i'd be looking for um yeah also i think dubai
is kind of an interesting one to see how that's
developing oh i disagree with you on that one i'll
go i'm sorry you you speak just that they're like
you know tax-free and crypto friendly i don't know
my thing with dubai is like it's so inauthentic
like the whole place is just like this is
the whole thing is so inauthentic
so like i don't for a second believe
that it's pro crypto because like for me like
what is pro crypto like what is pro bitcoin it's
like freedom independence um but like in dubai
i think when someone just snaps their fingers
you know you could have that taken away easily so
i just don't i just don't trust i just don't trust
that the intentions are good for me the whole
that whole thing with dubai so inauthentic i just
feel really weird about it well that's good we'll
keep an eye on that one we'll see how it develops
but portugal i want to come to el salvador
i'm really um intrigued um do you think the
rest of latin america are going to follow
yeah well there's a lot of interest yeah
yeah from other countries in south america um
and what was it oh it's escaping me jamaica
was like doing gonna be the next to launch a cbdc
or something that's not the same thing obviously
but uh yeah i think i think uh there's probably
countries now that are waiting to see like okay so
el salvador like stepped out right right okay
we're gonna do it and then it's a bear market
so people are gonna feel like okay we'll see
ya we'll see how they do and then if they can
come out on top okay we'll we'll back that up
as well but yeah uh it's it's pretty exciting
times to be able to to see this and uh to have
the freedom of flowing information that we have
now compared to say like you know even 30 years
ago with the internet like it's pretty cool to to
to be able to watch this unfold in a probably the
most honest way that we could possibly understand
how it's happening yeah no i totally agree with
you it's an insane time to be alive i mean we
spoke at the beginning of conversation about the
american dream being dead but in my eyes this is
sort of like the new american dream but it's like
the global dream it's like the individual dream
um and so yeah i think it's fascinating
to to watch it all play out um but heidi
how can people follow you see what you're up to
your youtube channel like show yourself how can
people get in touch with you yeah so we post
videos every day on youtube it's crypto tips
i don't know if they say my little name tag
there it's the same thing that we have there
um on twitter it is blockchain chick check
the spelling scammers are everywhere um
yeah we also have a we have a patreon group called
the ct club i just go to patreon.comcryptotips i'm
on instagram to oh i'm sorry why i'm on tiktok i'm
trying out that are you on tick tock yet yeah i
want to take talk it's a weird experience but i'm
slightly addicted to it it's actually very good
yeah we're on tick-tock it's real crypto tips
because someone already took our name of course
but yeah you can find us there that's perfect
guys please go follow heidi it's so great to
see people who are so awake to everything that's
going on right now the youtube channel is pretty
amazing um so many amazing crypto tips as the
name says so heidi thank you so much for coming
on it's been such a pleasure having you yeah
thank you leia it's been great absolutely and
guys please don't forget to hit the subscribe
button um so you never miss a video and i think
my mic kind of cut out at the beginning so i just
want to let you know this is sponsored by bitmex
they are an og crypto exchange they've just
launched an amazing spot exchange platform
so if you do want to join them the information
is in the description so go check them out so
we will see you all next week and thank you
so much for tuning in bye bye ohio pancho
you